Hey youtubers, it's Charlie.
So we just found out like 99% of the cast of Captain America Civil War is going to be.
So this is going to be a breakdown and an early preview of some of the new characters.
So just to talk about the new characters first...
Martin Freeman probably going to be playing Everett Ross...
His characters also be part of the black panther film
and Everett Ross is like a black panther
character. His someone that works for the
government so he works well
in both universes especially considering
all the politics that are going to be
going on in Captain America: Civil War
the characters can like a government
liaison but you can see how casting
Martin Freeman
they want a little bit drama-comedy.
Marvel films in general tend to be a
little bit lighter
you know that they like the DC films
which are really super dark and gritty
so you wondering what they may be
going toward just because Martin Freeman
has done some really
ridiculous comedy like the office the
British version the office
I'm expecting a performance closer to
the typeof comedy you would see in an
episode of Sherlock
really gripping drama with comedy in it.
The Everett Ross character in the comic
books can lend themselves to that
just imagine a Watson type character
reacting to crazy superheroes
Their bringing back William Hurt as
General Thadeus Ross from incredible Hulk
that's a deep cut... It also lends a little
more credence to the Everett Ross character.
That was one of the biggest casting
surprises.. Just because we haven't seen him in so long.
you can see his character is perfect for
civil war. There will be no question as
to which side he's going to fall on
they haven't officially confirmed Daniel
Brühl's character but he is dollars to donuts Baron Heinrich Zemo
just like Martin Freeman is supposed to
also appear in Black Panther
is a rumor that Daniel Bruhl is also
going to appear in Doctor Strange
That's speculation right now but you can
see how hydra would still be a thing in
the era of civil war
you know next year and in the timeline,
it's really only gonna be like a year after this.
it's not like it's gonna pick up years
and years after Age of Ultron.
More heads of the Hydra rising up;Baron
Zemo's just like one of the biggest
Marvel comic book characters they
haven't done yet
there's also a loose ties to mysticism
which you know could be the in for Doctor Strange.
Moving further down the list, another
really big surprise, Paul Rudd's Ant-man
is going to be in the movie... Just because
Hawkeyes gonna be in the movie too
when I really wanna see is him stick
Ant-man on the end up one is
arrows and fire at him and do like the arrow punch
just like in the cartoons
that be so hilarious... creative use of Ant-man.
Remember in the trailer, Hope Van Dyne
said "you're like a bullet"
so why wouldn't hawkeye fire him on one of his arrows
And then essentially the entire roster of the New Avengers...
So you have the Vision, Scarlet Witch, Black Widow, Falcon and War Machine.
and but those are asking yes, Bucky is
in the movie
Winter Soldier is coming back. He's so
important to the Captain America character.
there's no way he'd ride the bench. There
was a small Falcon easter egg during
Avengers Age of Ulton
where they were like "hey where you been?"and he's like "I've been on a missing person's case"
that just means in the time between Winter Soldier and Age of Ultron
he been tracking down winter soldier or
trying to.
There's a lot of rumors that Cap might die and Bucky might take up the
shield.
There's a number of characters like in the comics right now
Captain America is the Falcon but if you
go further back in the comics then
Winter Soldier became captain america:
certain point so
their number of candidates I think they
would go with the Bucky character
it be something up a redemption for his
character
Frank Grillo is coming back as Crossbones
remember at the end a
Winter Soldier he got his face
completely messed up so he look a lot
more like its comic book character
he and Chris Evans were actually
exchanging mean tweets with each other i
mean they were joking
but Frank Griller was basically telling Chris Evans he's going to beat the crap out of him
Emily Van Camp's Agent 13 is coming back too.
her show on ABC just got cancelled...
She was on revenge
there's a lot of theories that she might
do another Marvel TV show
but for now she's gonna be in this Marvel
film... they're gonna be filming for a long time too
how serendipitous! you know I'm sure she
would have been in the movie anyway even
if her show didn't get cancelled
but now I think they can just make her part little bit
bigger. I think part of the disappointment with
her character in Winter Soldier
is that she almost wasn't there. She probably
had more scenes that just got cut out but
now they can feature her little bit more.
Because she's a really interesting part
of the Captain America comics
and of course Black Panther is going to
be making his debut in the movie
and when I say debut he's going to be in
his Vibranium costume
I've already done a couple videos for the Black
Panther movies so I'll add a link in the description
but essentially, you know his costume
isn't just a normal suit.
it's made of Vibranium Weave. Doesn't it just
remind you of that Ultron joke in the movie
"the most versatile substance on Earth and
humans use it to make a frisbee"
those were my favorite quotes from the
movie...
We do not see Ulysses Klaw on the cast list
Andy Serkis isn't supposed to be in the movie
him as far as we know I totally don't
have a problem with that
because we already have like half the
cast of Age of Ultron coming to this next movie.
Civil War is basically like Avengers 2.5
you have so many Avengers in it... you might
as well call it that.
For those who are wondering about the presence of Iron Man in the movie
You know it means
Captain America movie but you have a lot
of a-list Avengers especially Robert
Downey Jr.
yes he's gonna be on screen lot but is
still gonna focus on Captain America's character
Robert Downey Jr. made this big deal
after he re-upped his contract about
stepping down his presence in the movies
but still appearing
he still wants to be Tony Stark, He still going
to be that character but
he just he's not gonna be headlining as
many movies as he did in phase 1 and phase 2
that's where you don't see a solo Iron
Man film on the books in phase 3
him unofficially retiring from the
Avengers at Age of Ultron
is kinda the transition. Like he's slowly
stepping his presence down...
But its not like he's quitting the Marvel Universe
He's not pulling a Hulk and going off the
grid
For those are wondering where the hulk is too.
he just wondering around he's trying to
be away from people
he'll totally be back for Infinity War, don't worry
about that.
Any of the Avengers that you don't see in Captain America: Civil War
will be back for Infinity War, at least
part 2 if it's not part 1
there's a lot of theories that you know
anybody the dies in Captain America: Civil War
might not come back right away
in Avengers: infinity war part 1
they just started to write for that movie. And they've
already said part 1 and part 2
aren't going to be like one film split in
half. their gonna be two distinct storylines
there's a number of things that could mean but
you know it's not like secret wars,
where it's like this big giant event series just split into
parts
Here's my big question for you guys, you know who
are you most excited to see in
Captain America: Civil War
right now I'm you know most excited to see
more from Scarlet Witch
and the Vision. They have such unique
powers that we haven't seen the Marvel
Universe yet that I i feel like it's
going to be so much fun by just seeing what they do.
in yes I totally think that they're
gonna push that ship
They're going to have a relationship
it will be a big falling out that you know the
weave in along the classic comics
Vision/Scarlet Witch were always a big
thing you know but across the comics you know they
broke up, they had phantom babies that turn of to be Mephisto. I just-I can't wait to
see how ridiculous they get with it
As for characters dying though, I know everyone's
asking about Quicksilver in Age of Ultron
you know if you know captain America ends up dying then that's an even bigger deal
The Time Gem is really the work around to that
Once you have the gauntlet, you can change anything you want.
so they could hold the Time gem to
infinity war part 1
in that could be the way to bring back
any dead big franchise characters
really I think Thor 3 is going to be our
next gem based you know huge WTF space movie
Guardians of The Galaxy is gonna be pretty
crazy too so I-You know I think they'll try to integrate some of that.
but the most gem related stuff I'm
expecting out of that movie
it just Thanos himself talking about
the gems.
You can only use gems as the MacGuffin in big Marvel films a
certain number times
You can't do it in every single film
As of right now, we still need the Soul Gem, still need the Time Gem.
it would be fun to see the soul gem show
up in Doctor Strange
And have it be like the Eye of Aggamotto. But they can go in any direction they want to with it.
also along those lines know that
Benedict Cumberbatch is not on the cast list for civil war.
part of that is because the actor isn't
available, I'm sure if he had the time
he would totally cameo. In speaking of
which, posts credit scenes.
a lot of that's done during reshoots like
months and months
after they wrapped principal photography...
so we could still see them setting up
Carol Danvers/Captain Marvel, Doctor
Strange
you know a number a big characters that
we just haven't met yet.
They also have to start weaving in power people you know Inhumans to the movies
I'll be interested to see how they do that
because we don't have any big in humans
characters cast yet
when I think the priority in terms in
new characters is weaving Black Panther into the mythos.
gotta get some more by Vibranium.
Speaking of which I know a lot of you are wondering about Iron Man's New Suit
He had a new suit at the end of Age of Ultron that they totally did not mention.
It looks a lot like the bleeding edge
armor from invincible iron-man number 25
that's actually kinda a riff on the Iron
Man armor from the first film
just you know with vastly upgraded parts
They didn't really address it in the films in terms of them getting
More Vibranium just because the
vision was all the Vibranium Ultron took.
I do think at some point he's going to
make a new suit out of Vibranium.
it would be stupid for him to not so I
think it depends on what the
relationship with Wakanda going to be at the end of Civil War
Spiderman's a big question mark
we know is going to be in the film in
some way but they're still finalizing
the contract
on the actor it down to like the final
list of candidates
there's Asa Butterfield, Tom Holland
Timothy Shella Mae
I feel like any those choices will be
fine. The rumors right now for like the
Sony spider-man solar films the ones
they're making with Marvel
are going to be him in sophomore junior
and senior year
of high school you know be like a new
trilogy that means that he might be
a freshman in captain america: Civil War
just so they can integrate the Sony
films into the Marvel MCU
timeline in a logical way
Kevin Fiege did say that there is like
a teenage spider-man
swinging around in New York City right
now you know in the time line
the people just don't know about. The
costume he has is going to be way more
tuned down
something way closer to when a high
schooler would come up with
I don't think that means it's gonna look
cosplay but if Brian Michael Bendis
has his way he will have his mechanical
web shooters
So know that who's some of the characters
are what I'm probrably gonna do is targets some
more bonus videos on characters like
do some Scarlet Witch/Vision videos is
going to be a lot of fun so be sure to subscribe
to get everything
it is anything you guys really want me
to do just let me know in a comment I've
also got some Ant-man Videos that I'm working on soon just because that movie is like a a couple of months away.
so while you guys wait for that stuff, you can
click here for my Black Panther video
and you can click here to learn about
all the big cuts be made from Age of Ultron
Thank you so much for watching, everybody let's high five. I'll see you guys tonight! :)